believe subh wow one second one
second okay so this is this is this is
your mom's
Idol regularly wow wow look at that this
is who you write this but what if your
mom sees it yes I I hide this hide
this just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on y that you read it wherever you
was
hello hello bro I please guide me I want
to join Islam I am a Hindu I am from
Hindu family Indian I want to join Islam
but my
parents I don't know what they will
think about this I'm a student 70 years
old from India please guide
me so you want to join Islam but you are
afraid what your parents will
think I don't know what my parents will
think did you okay look your parents
look my parents my dad didn't like it
but that shouldn't stop stop you from
accepting the truth and you don't need
to tell them you don't need to tell them
bro
okay so you can you can take your
shahada with
us well I will become Islam Then I then
I will join Hindu festival
rituals I can not not you should you
shouldn't you shouldn't join the
festival shouldn't do that but like you
should avoid it as much as possible you
shouldn't join it obviously unless
you're fool somebody fools you that's
that's not in your heart you know you
don't believe that so I would say um
accept Islam and then after that inshah
we'll talk about the other stuff like
you know try to avoid going to these
festivals Etc
in how and my question is that how but
uh we should do the namas also I had
that then yeah try to try to pray try to
pray in
secret at home without M it
possible sorry say that
again uh without m without M it it is
possible to yeah you yeah yeah you can
pray anywhere any anywhere as long as
it's clean you can play anywhere you
don't need to pray in the mid you can
pray anywhere learn this thing so that's
the
problem what you oh you want to so okay
you can order this mat you know if you
go to Salah
plus.com I don't know but uh from zero
starting from zero okay that's the
problem starting from zero I don't know
anything you you can see that uh my
mother also her see uh what here Idol
but you can see that but
one where is the idol let's see let's go
to this video one second can we add one
second that's the
temph W one second
one okay so this is this is this is your
mom's
Idol no my
mom's yeah sh does this say that
[Music]
again
regularly so one second let's let's
let's see that again let's see that so
so one second one second okay one second
so turn turn it to the idol let's see it
who is this what is this
Idol can we see it again can we see
again
please so this is what your mom prays
to yes yes okay why is there lights why
is there lights does your mom does your
mom give foods to these Idols does she
give them Foods or stuff yes yes that's
called Prasad okay yes yes wow who's
that person in the picture there who's
that person in the
picture uh in Indian in in India it's
called Uh Guru takur yeah Guru takur yes
Guru takur we should follow the uh path
of uh PA we should follow their path
okay uh oh like like like like is he
like a prophet like oh we follow his is
like G does he claim to be God he's not
he's not God you don't see as to be God
Jesus Jesus Etc he is the messenger okay
you said he is the messenger okay he so
he's he's like a he's like a
messenger okay let's go to the idol can
I get a closer look to the ID please can
I I just want to see what kind of ID is
it the one okay one how many how many
Idols are there how many Idols are
there
uh okay
that's Subhan Allah bro there people
that like Subhan Allah Subhan Allah and
you want to accept Islam brother listen
to me listen to me you know you are
Allah Allah has guided you why how did
you come across Islam how did you come
across
Islam wow wow look at that this is who
you write this but what if your mom sees
it yes I I hide this hide this behind
you hide this let me see let me see
where he hi this is profound wow one
second so let's see the picture where
did you write I love
Allah okay
yes I hope brothers and sisters you can
see what is happening here so where do
where do you hide this where do you hide
this uh from my mom my mom spoiled
me okay why why why did you write I love
Allah on that picture why did you write
I love Allah on that picture because the
concept of Allah you see that uh Allah
is everything that in Hinduism we follow
so many God but in Islam we follow one
true God that's the reason we is subh
this this is profound he he's in you're
in India can I ask you a question how
did you come across Islam who told you
about
Islam I like that I like that I like
that how how you how you know about
Islam who tell you about Islam how did
you find Islam
English how I
find
difficult answer this question but I
like the concept okay like the concept
okay but where did you where did you
find it's the information of Islam who
told you your friend video where you I
search quran.com I see I read the uh uh
Quran I see the quran.com okay that's
why
you Ali bukari small I know about very
small things about Islam uh very primary
things you can
say subh so you went to quran.com you
started reading the Quran and had how
did you come across this video how did
you find this video here this video this
live how did you come across
it that's uh I I know I know all Islamic
YouTuber like
ta wow okay and what's that smile smile
to smile to
J wow this is this is this is profound
brother Subhan Allah just one second so
guys who are watching this this is a
Indian boy in India he showed his idols
of his mom he's written on a picture I
love Allah Allah subhana wa tala has
brought him hiah guidance look at him
all the way in India he's in a room
where his mom is worshiping Idols he
showed us the idols you want to accept
Islam with us how old are you 17 do you
want to accept Islam with us why don't
you take your shahada with us
now uh I like the concept okay that
Islam
uh says about everything that without
Allah the we can't move a leaf okay uh
that's you can see that how the
everything on Earth that perfectly
designed okay perfectly designed as a
human body perfectly designed yes so I
love the concept uh that I don't know
that Idol or or not but but I love the
uh I believe the power that I believe
the power who uh manage the so okay so
you believe look there is one God we
don't believe in million Gods there is
one ultimate Creator Allah do you accept
this yes yes yes okay we don't believe
that Allah is everywhere we don't
believe this we say Allah's knowledge is
everywhere Allah knows we don't believe
Allah is everywhere so we say Allah
obviously you will know this slowly so
you accept that Allah's knowledge is
everywhere yes Allah is not everywhere
correct yes yes okay you Worship You
Believe in one God yeah only one God no
other gods yes yes okay do you accept
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
as a final
messenger I only I don't know that the
history I
don't know about the uh history and the
all the
Quran I know a small thing about Islam
that I okay like about it I like about
it okay so do you believe the Quran is
from Allah the Quran is from
God and the fun fact is you don't win a
you don't win a debate uh uh you don't
WI a debate
against the Islamic scholar they are
highly qualified about their religion I
like that thing that they follow
their very perfectly yes yes
so do you sorry do you believe the Quran
is from Allah do you accept that the
Quran is from Allah obviously yes okay
so if you believe this then you also
would believe the prophet Muhammad is
the final messenger
because the Quran was revealed to him do
you accept this yes yes okay do you want
to join Islam now you repeat the shahada
with
us
yes okay repeat after she Muhammad
please yeah so repeat after him and from
now on you don't worship any Idols you
don't need to break them this is this
belongs to your mom you can we are not
asking you to do that that's your mom's
but from now on you will worship Allah
Allah has no image there is nothing like
like him he he's he's not a he does not
beget he's not begotten okay you worship
the one true creator repeat after she
muhamad please
yes okay
brother yes
Uncle so repeat after me yes I
testify yes repeat again I
testify I
testify that there is that that is no
one no one
worthy worthy of
worship
worship except except Allah Allah and I
testify and I justify that Muhammad that
Muhammad is his final is his final
messenger
messenger so let's say it in
[Music]
Arabic Allah
Allah
as
muhamad
Mamu Allah
Allah you are a Muslim now my brother
you are 17y old Muslim in India where
Subhan Allah Idols if you can show the
idols again for the people who want to
work just show can you see the idols
again of your your mom's Idols so guys
look at this yeah
look at this guys subh look these are
his mom's Idol subh Allah as you can see
there uh I'm assuming a lot of Hindus
have this in their house they have a
specific Corner guys uh and Allah says
in the Quran look they give them food
that if a fly was to come and snatch
that away from them they don't even have
the capabilities to defend theel Subhan
Allah this is what Islam has come to
free the Mankind from worshiping Idols
associate Partners to Allah subhana tala
stones
look at this look at this subh okay may
Allah bless you we are going to send you
I don't know if this will reach India
we're going to try to send you this so
you can start praying brother can you
see
this yes yes can you please put your
details on the private
chat your number on the private chat we
are going to send this to India okay I'm
going to send it usually we charge a
postal fee only International orders I'm
going to pay for it myself insh we are
going to send you this you can start
praying Salah okay yes yes okay and and
and leave your contact details so we can
speak to you in and give you the support
and don't forget you have Allah worship
Allah alone anytime you're in difficulty
worship Allah you don't need any Idol
you don't need any of this stuff you
worship Allah alone okay okay brother
okay from now one you are a muslim
okay please put your details on the
private chat you know the private chat
do you know no I don't know about the
private chat one second one second We
messaged you now can you see
it okay I see I see can you see
it okay stay there we're going to
message you now
okay your mobile number here okay okay
but I am from India and you from UK okay
International I
have we will send it to
you
it's fine put your number there I am
going to message you and I'm going to
send you this gu of prayer mat okay
country code request country code
country country code okay no no I we'll
find it just send us your details you
send us your details in the private chat
you know the private chat just send your
details there I see I see I see I see
send your details there okay brother
take care Salam alaykum